[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de 7,8 échos le magazine consacré à
l'actualité économique de notre
territoire
voici le sommaire et rénovation d'un
complexe sportif pour bouygues
construction ou encore les jeux
olympiques en 2024 accompagné par le
groupe d'ingénierie egis dans ce numéro
nous nous intéresserons aux entreprises
saint-quentinoise impliqué dans le sport
est des concertations pour développer le
commerce sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines l'agglomération
vient de lancer une série de réunions
afin de faire un état des lieux mais
aussi avoir un retour sur les
problématiques rencontrées
enfin nous ferons un point sur le reste
de l'actualité économique dans notre
département avec la date de la troisième
édition du sky business des qui vient
d'être dévoilée focus également sur
l'association libre réseau à cette
association regroupe une vingtaine
d'entrepreneurs du territoire objectif
mettre en commun leurs réseaux
mais avant de développer tous ces titres
on va démarrer avec un chiffre à 209
millions d'euros c'est la somme que la
région ile de france investira en
équipements publics pour les jo de 2024
hier à la remis au comité international
olympique sa feuille de route sur la
stratégie régionale olympique est 18
engagements ont été pris comme la
formation de 70 mille volontaires bien
encore renforcer l'accessibilité des
gares d'ici 2024
les jo-2020 24 on en reparle plus
longuement dans quelques minutes
mais avant on va parler commerce premier
pôle commercial de notre département
saint quentin en yvelines vient de
lancer une série de rencontres objectif
faire le point sur la stratégie
commerciale de l'agglomération mais
aussi avoir un retour auprès des
commerçants sur les problématiques
rencontrées premières zones concernées
maurepas coignet reportage une première
concertation qui commence tout d'abord
par un état des lieux avec plus de 500
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
annuel la zone maurepas coignières est
le deuxième pôle majeur de
l'agglomération sur les 160 mille mètres
carrés de zone commerciale on dénombre
250 magasins qui génère plus de 2 me
emploi un territoire qui présente donc
de nombreuses forces
même si les commerçants présents ont
pointé du doigt quelques faiblesses je
m'aperçois que cette zone a des petits
problèmes de fréquentation on a une zone
qui est un petit peu désertique en
semaine et j'étais très très inquiet de
la non réactivité je suis venu ici pour
m'informer et j'en ressors un peu plus
satisfait car je m'aperçois que d'autres
gens que moir ont les mêmes soucis
les interrogations et travaille au
développement de cette zone
pour moi c'est super important quand on
doit s'adresser à quelqu'un on n'a
souvent pas le bonnet interlocuteurs ça
passe d'un nom à laudun non à l'autre et
on arrive souvent pas à voir la personne
dont on a besoin et donc là ça permet
pas ce que tout le monde se connaît on
sait à peu près qui va s'occuper de quoi
mieux connaître les attentes des
commerçants des propriétaires et des
gestionnaires de sites afin de
développer au mieux cette zone
voici l'objectif de saint quentin en
yvelines pour repenser la stratégie
commerciale du territoire il y aura
d'autres évidemment réunion mais on
reste toujours maintenant en contact
parce que l'objectif c'est aussi d'avoir
leurs coordonnées d'avoir aussi
d'évolution de chiffre d'affaires pour
voir un peu comment il se situe
prochaines zones concernées par ces
concertations plaisir et les
clayes-sous-bois en octobre prochain
dans son jour saint quentin en yvelines
accueillera la ryder cup cette
compétition de golf est le troisième
événement sportif le plus suivi au monde
notre territoire qui accueillera
également dans six ans et tenté un petit
peu plus loin plusieurs épreuves des jo
de 2024
l'occasion donc de faire le point sur
ces entreprises saint-quentinoise
tournée vers le sport comme vous allez
le voir dans ce sujet proposé par la
rédaction de tv 78
[Musique]
fédérer les salariés autour des valeurs
du sport
le 31 mai dernier plus de 600 personnes
ont participé au trophée des entreprises
de saint quentin en yvelines
un rendez vous inscrit depuis maintenant
10 ans sur le planning des grands
groupes pme et agents du territoire
l'élan du sport c'est bien sûr être le
meilleur mais en même temps il ya
beaucoup de sport d'équipé où là il faut
pas être seulement le meilleur il faut
être celui qui apporte le plus de valeur
ajoutée au groupe plus values motivation
et performances des termes comme un
aujourd'hui au sport et aux entreprises
saint-quentinoise qui n'hésitent pas à
investir dans leurs infrastructures
exemple à guyancourt avec le nouveau
complexe sportif de bouygues
construction
le site de 4 hectares et demi qu'on
prend des cours de tennis couverts des
terrains de squash terrains de football
ou encore un espace pour le golf
tout a été refait à neuf pour le
bien-être et des 2500 collaborateurs
nous avons l'ambition de effectivement
de créer une émulation saine et sportif
de l'entreprise mais aussi d'extérieur
[Musique]
dans le cadre notamment d'une aspect qui
est à la mode la qualité de vie au
travail
il est important que le cab orateurs
puissent bénéficier d'installations de
l'équipe
avant d'effectivement revenir faire du
sport le midi le soir en toute
tranquillité avec des installations
dignes de ce nom
[Musique]
le sport qui sera plus que jamais
présents sur notre territoire dans six
ans avec les jeux olympiques à saint
quentin en yvelines quatre sites ont été
retenus pour accueillir des épreuves des
sites proposés par egis un des acteurs
clés du dossier paris 2024 dont le siège
est basé à guyancourt
on a aidé la ville de paris le comité de
candidature à choisir les sports le
bâtiment pour mieux placer le discipline
et notamment avec un écart de
des responsables étaient de on était
toujours très concerné par rapport le
coût des jo qui aussi par rapport le
développement durable le groupe de
conseil et d'ingénierie a notamment
réalisé la plupart des stades qui ont
servi pour l'euro 2016 de football
challenge pour les jo que les sites
soient réutilisables après 2024 dans un
souci d'économie on a toujours
l'intention de de de faire une bonne et
d'avoine dans les étages et il avait le
temps d'un de 50 ans elle est parfait
pour accueillir les épreuves des jo bien
sûr il faut lui habillé c'est le
vélodrome il faut préparer parce qu'il
ya quand même pas mal d'athlètes qui
arrivent beaucoup de compétition
beaucoup de discipline
donc il ya quelques préparations a fermé
son de préparation temporaire les jo
2024 une opportunité économique pour les
entreprises de notre territoire
si pour l'instant aucun chiffre n'est
communiqué sur les retombées économiques
attendues
ce rendez vous sportif devrait créer 250
mille emplois deux cent cinquante mille
emplois c'est justement le chiffre mis
en avant il ya quelques semaines par le
medef l'organisation patronale a
présenté une plateforme intitulé
entreprises 2024 elle permettra dès le
1er octobre aux entrepreneurs d'avoir un
accès privilégié aux appels d'offres
liés aux jo de 2024 reportage
informations sur les jeux olympiques de
2024 appel à projets appel d'offres ou
encore emploi en lançant la plateforme
entreprises 2024 le medef souhaite faire
profiter les entreprises de cette
opportunité économique le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines sera
particulièrement concernée puisque
quatre sites accueilleront des épreuves
le rendez-vous est dans six ans et
pourtant c'est maintenant qu'il faut
anticiper n'a pas du tout droit à
l'erreur c'est la planète qui nous
regardent et c'est un vrai facteur de
rayonnement pour la france que d'avoir
l'accueil de ces jeux olympiques
donc on ne te va souper et donc c'est de
la préparation et de la planification la
plateforme entreprises 2024 également
dédié aux associations sera mise en
route dès le 1er octobre 2018 pour
l'instant aucun chiffre précis sur les
retombées économiques
les jeux olympiques devrait néanmoins
créé 250 mille emplois pour 50 ans avec
les sites qui existent déjà il ya une
part hôtelière il part dans le bâtiment
c'est une vraie opportunité s'il y a un
manque de main d'oeuvre présence
certains secteurs et on mettra en place
des formations en adéquation avec la
demande
lors de cette présentation de sportif
françois pervis et quentin la fa non
partagé avec les entrepreneurs leur
parcours et leur motivation pour
atteindre le plus haut niveau qu'on est
patron d'une entreprise ou salarié ou
collaborateurs on a des objectifs de
réussite
et forcément quand on est sportif de
haut niveau c'est la même chose tout
comme les sportifs les entrepreneurs
yvelinois pourront mettre toutes leurs
chances de leur côté grâce à cette
plateforme pour profiter au mieux de
l'événement la bonne santé financière de
saint quentin en yvelines ont encore une
association qui met en réseau les
entrepreneurs de notre département
elle s'est tout de suite dans les
courbes bref deux lettres pour saluer la
bonne santé financière de saint quentin
en yvelines
l'agencé internationale de notation
standard and poor's vient de confirmer
la note de aa - déjà attribué en
décembre dernier cette notation facilite
notamment l'obtention de prêts à taux
d'intérêt compétitif selon un communiqué
cela certifie également la gestion
rigoureuse de l'argent des contribuables
de l'agglomération
ils se retrouvent ici tous les vendredis
matin dans ce restaurant d'elancourt
libre réseau est une association qui
existe depuis sept ans objectif pour les
23 membres mettre en commun leurs
réseaux et faire en sorte que chacun
puisse bénéficier de recommandation une
règle à respecter il ne peut pas y avoir
plusieurs membres issus du même secteur
d'activité on est tous des petits
entrepreneurs donc entrepreneurs
indépendants ou chefs d'entreprises avec
moins de 10 salariés et donc le réseau
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment pour nous une
opportunité de nous faire connaître les
valeurs sont très importantes
donc c'est le respect c'est la
bienveillance c'est à dire que ce ne
sont pas ces certes c'est un réseau
business mais ça un réseau dans lequel
on se réunit toutes les semaines donc ce
qui est important c'est qu'on se sente
bien dans ce réseau les chefs
d'entreprise de saint quentin en
yvelines ont rendez vous le jeudi 8
novembre pour la troisième édition du
sky business des cette convention
d'affaires réunis au vélodrome nationale
grands groupes pme et tpe
tout au long de la journée des rendez
vous sont organisés en fonction des
besoins et des attentes exprimées par
les entreprises
l'année dernière elles étaient plus de
600 à participer les pré inscriptions
sont d'ores et déjà possibles sur
www.skype.com
cette émission touche bientôt à sa fin
mais avant de se quitter voyons ensemble
les rendez vous économiques qui vous
attendent
mardi 26 juin de 18 heures à 20 heures
un atelier intitulé le prélèvement à la
source est organisée au ski cuba
guyancourt la participation est gratuite
mais il faut s'inscrire sur le site
www.skype.com le vendredi 29 juin de
8h30 à 10h30 si vous voulez en savoir
plus sur la transition digital pour
votre entreprise et bien rendez vous là
aussi au ski cube à guyancourt il faut
également s'inscrire sur le site
www.skype.com enfin mercredi 4 juillet
de 9h à 14h une matinée justement sur
les enjeux économiques et des jo-2000 24
aura lieu à l'estaca c'est à montigny le
bretonneux
l'événement est organisé par les pôles
de compétitivité movéo et systématique
plus d'informations sur le site qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran
voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi 3
juillet pour un nouveau cette ut co
consacrée notamment au numérique et à la
cybersécurité à très bientôt
[Musique]